good morning Hank it's Monday so this is
Jonathan Coulton he's a singer
songwriter family man all-around nice
guy bought me a beer once but for our
purposes today he is a small media
company and this is Viacom also a media
company somewhat larger ok and now this
is a snippet from a Jonathan Coulton
video called flicker smiles in the cold
red light of dawn and eagle eye
and the matter happy wearing matching
ties
a pair of food
broken finger
and so below
female Klingon strum sexy lady
party's better than it seems one baby
deer sleeping giant panda pleasant
dreams
Brens Oh miss P Jonathan Coulton found a
bunch of images on Flickr that had a
Creative Commons license and then he
turned them into a nonsense crazy funny
song which he then released under a
Creative Commons license saying you can
share this you can remix it all you have
to do is atribute it to me and not make
money off of it which is why you don't
see an ad next to my head today Hank but
more on that in a second so Hank as you
explained in your excellent video on
Friday Viacom is suing YouTube for a
billion dollars because one Viacom
believes the YouTube only became popular
by using pirated content and that
therefore Viacom is owed a portion of
YouTube's like overall value by which
measure YouTube does a Viacom some money
but not nearly as much money as it owes
lonely girl 15 in that evolution of a
dance guy also to YouTube made
advertising money off content owned by
Viacom now like everybody agrees that
YouTube ought to pay Viacom that ad
money but the amount is in dispute
YouTube thinks that you should have to
pay what online video advertising is
Worf
whereas Viacom thinks that YouTube
should pay what online video advertising
would be worth if we lived in a land of
money trees and candy fountains right so
but anyway Hank in your video on Friday
you mentioned that Viacom owns its own
video sharing website spike com that led
me to do some digging thank you can
probably see where this is going when
you go to Viacom's website spike calm
and you search for Jonathan Coulton
you can watch Jonathan Colton's Flickr
video only before you watch it you have
to watch an advertisement for a cell
phone and then while you're watching it
you get to look at advertisements for
Mountain Dew and American Express and
Guitar Hero in short Viacom is doing two
Jonathan Coulton in 2010 what YouTube
was doing to Viacom in 2006 now Hank
when this is pointed out to Viacom they
may take down the video but you can't
unmake money you already made that video
has been viewed more than 18,000 times
on Spike com now if we use the same
insane mathematical formula that Viacom
used to calculate how much YouTube
should owe them Viacom owns Jonathan
Coulton thirteen thousand eight hundred
twenty three dollars but it may be that
in this particular instance Viacom
doesn't want to use crazy math they want
to use real math in which case they owed
Jonathan Coulton thirty seven dollars so
Hank here's my question for Viacom where
is Jonathan Colton's thirty seven
dollars Hank I sent an email to Viacom
asking that very question if you were
any nerdfighters want to do the same
there's a link in my pants I think we
all know Viacom hates piracy so I'm sure
they'll pay Jonathan Coulton is 37
dollars unless of course they think
video views are really worth what they
say they think they're worth in which
case I'm sure they'll pay
his 13,800 $23 I mean the only other
possibility would be the Viacom thinks
the definition of piracy is stealing
from someone who has a lawyer that
doesn't seem like the Viacom I know and
love Hank Hank I'll see you on Wednesday